hello
hello we are
back notification
gang
sorry I started out a little bit later
than normal because I was watching uh
Triforce Trends
stream are we going to gudo town yes we
are I'm probably going to stream a
little less longer than normal because
because there is a Playstation state of
play I think in about 1 and a half to
two hours and I do want to check out if
they will show anything Silent Hill
related probably not hey isar what's
up how you
doing Wee
Woo got the first weoo of the of the
day
uhoh uh oh okay I think we're gonna
we're going to make
it how do you feel about this game
nowadays I think it's okay lorewise
there's not a lot to talk about uh at
least I cannot find much to talk
about I think most of the interesting
subjects I've already covered at this
point but you know maybe I will find
something else but uh yeah it's it it's
it's not really for
me like gameplay wise it is but
uh it was a fun first playr but I don't
think I'm going to be replaying this a
whole lot but that's okay yeah solid
seven out of 10 exactly
Kieran I just I I think if the game took
like 3 years to to finish then the
expectations would have been a little
bit
different but because it took 6 years I
think a lot of people were just like oh
this is going to be the biggest greatest
game of all
time and maybe for some it is but not
for me I think it's a little little too
derivative I think not enough was
different about the surface I think it
would have been better if they just went
with a completely different land
or like a different world or maybe uh
have most of it take place in the sky
and just have bigger sky islands and
more of
them sorry I destroyed your crates what
are you going to do what are you going
to do about it that's what I
thought oh yeah you got to talk to her
to open up the
door thank you thanks for being nice to
me yes
arrows I don't want you I want Arrow I
want
arrow is this where they call link
short he is a little bit of a little bit
short he's about the same size as a gudo
child but I don't think he is
necessarily super short he's it's just
that the gudo are
huge the grudo are so incredibly
tall
even herbosa was like ahead above Zelda
and Zelda's I would say average height
for but I think most hens are pretty
short in this game isn't there a hen in
the prison cell somewhere
here I expected it to be boai being in
inside the jail cell but it's actually
some other
dude I don't know where he is is it here
somewhere oh no this is the eth heroin
side quest
something I noticed is that every time
after my stream goes up uh the the ads
get limited they limit the ad uh thing
and then I oh there he is
yeah just he's just been thrown in
prison but yeah I I don't know what
happened usually I just request a a re
request a review and then after that
they approve and then it's fine again
but I I'm just wondering what causes it
to trigger that uh
response uh I think I have to talk to Ru
I'm not even sure why I'm in here oh
yeah I went here in here to buy arrows
open
up uh the green dragon says thank you
for your theory videos yours and other
zeld tubers are helping me with creating
my own web tune based on the legend of
Zelda man power to you being
creative where where can we find your uh
or is it still work in
progress isn't this the oldest Link in
the Zelda series I guess so if the if he
was 17 or 18 in the previous game and
this takes place like couple of years
after then he should be yeah in his
early
20s so yeah I guess so there there is a
list of the age of every
link but I don't know it from
memory oh my gosh
zeldor hi Clifford how you
doing you're the first member here yeah
I think so
too
yeah
oh yeah I'm doing good too nice of you
to uh drop by florai says greetings from
the ratosa community oh man I love
rasar he speaks truths he speaks his
mind I I appreciate
that he doesn't care if
people love him for it or or hate him
for it he just says whatever he
thinks he doesn't hold
back it's funny how I met rosar is
because he made a similar video to mine
and people started kind of suggesting
like oh someone already made a video
like
this and they pointed them him to my
video but it was just a coincidence he
he just happened to come up with a very
similar idea it wasn't even that similar
it was just one part of the video was
very similar the the part from Skyward
Sword where you can see the Triforce
reflection inside the Silent Realm in
the waking
water
geod Dragon says I'm just replaying
Pokemon Violet hope everyone is doing
good hope you're doing good too man and
uh I'm not a very big I'm not big on
Pokemon not since Pokemon Red on on Game
Boy
but I've never been a huge Pokemon guy
well back when I was still like saving
the cards and all that stuff oh yeah
I've got to talk to the
uh to the soldier
woman what's the plan I asked myself
that every day what's the
plan Green Dragon says it's a work in
progress but Zelda piics are on here and
Tik Tok okay
cool
awesome hey you did not miss
anything tell me about the
enemy the gibdos we've encountered in
the encountered in the desert do not
fall easily when struck oh yeah they do
just attach a firef fruit to your uh to
your
thingy no not your thingy your your
arrow
they will go down very very
quickly actually I should make a weapon
with
fire maybe a
spear uh yeah I should
probably do I have anything that I can
use a ruby I guess although I I kind of
want to sell that one for in case I need
more
arrows H I'll just use arrows it's more
it's more easy
anyway thingy oh my God what what mess
have I gotten myself
into oh it's still doing that black
thing again but it's not because of the
ultra cam by the way it's because of
some
other uh it's because of the
60fps mod I
think they do all have lightning Spears
I kind of like that the
tail how should we deploy our forces I
don't know you're the military General
and all that
stuff Kieran Buckley says do you think
we'll be there will be a Nintendo Direct
soon hoping for some T 2D Zelda lore uh
love 2D Zelda love not lore uh yeah it's
been too long it's been 84
years at least that's that's how it
feels like what when was Link Between
Worlds
2015 20
2013 actually let me let me look that up
real quick I'm I'm
curious 2013
okay yeah that's hella for no original
new 2D Zelda game only remakes or
ports we need to decide who to send
where where you like we'd like to hear
your
thoughts uh I think I always put the
cannon up front like uh on the north
gate because it's a
cannon pretty cool how they have a
cannon
uh the other one is kind of whatever
spear
troops we'll just spread our forces
out
I don't think it really matters
but we'll spread out our forces we we'll
we won't do a
300 and just funnel them bottleneck them
I think we're we're good to go
then make no changes yeah okay CU I got
to talk to reu
again
man I got to upgrade my stamina at some
point Shirak Kuma says do you like the
studio
gibl uh Zelda movie idea from fans oh
yeah I mean ran Link's video kind of
showed that it would be it it could be
amazing for sure if one guy can do that
imagine a whole
team a says I kind I kind of like 2D
games but the comp comparison I made
with Wind Waker when I played Phantom
Hourglass traumatized me well Phantom
Hourglass is kind of we like a weird
hybrid when it comes the 2D Zelda games
I also didn't like the controls a
lot and it's one ugly ass
game it's really really ugly in my
opinion but that's that's me I would
never want to revisit either of the 2D
or the 3DS titles
personally
if they had normal controls and maybe a
slightly different art style then yeah
for
sure that's why I hate making videos
that include Phantom Hourglass and
spirit tracks because the lore uh is
really
interesting but getting goodlook footage
for it is so so
difficult
even like emulating it it doesn't make a
whole because you know you got to deal
with the whole touchcreen stuff you
cannot really emulate that very easily
unless you have very specific
Hardware oh there we
go Clifford says 2013 we got two the
Zelda games a new one Link Between
Worlds and HD remaster of previous
installment the wind wer
situation
report large numbers of gibdos are
moving to attack the
town so it
begins it's okay to like uh Phantom
Hourglass and Spirit Tracks it's just
not I couldn't get over the
controls I don't like using the stylist
to move him around if it was only for
like solving puzzles or like drawing a
path for the boomerang that would have
been fine I just don't really like the
move just walking around just dragging
over the screen I didn't like that for
Mario DS either but at least there you
could change the controls I I
believe
gios used to be mummies now they are
zombie bugs what a world yeah zom
bugs at man she's got some range on
that enemies have emerged from The Hive
at the East Gate stop
them if I had more stamina I could get
there easily more
easily oh I'm an old man I'm so
tired enemies are pouring out of the
near the take them
out yeah I cannot be in multiple places
at at the same time give me a break
here I think I got to destroy the hives
or else they'll just keep
spawning that is out
of
enem you can you guys can handle these
right
no I'll give you a little little help
with
that I'm surprised jumping doesn't take
away stamina in most games usually
jumping takes up a whole bunch of
stamina
there's one
lonely gibo right here enemies
enemies that's the last of the all we
have to do
now oh no they're crawling
enem oh shoot
en center of
town oh
god oh and I'm out of stamina all
right
uhoh and I'm out of stamina again oh man
I really got to upgra upgrade my stamina
a ru's got
this or what's that
bullara I think we got all of them
right oh there's one
more
boom these guda Warriors are
useless yeah they kind of are aren't
they for
[Music]
Glory these gudo need need r Rick
Grimes I got that
reference yeah Rick Grimes would just
clear all of them out with one axe just
a tiny little
axe where did bullara get Faro's horn
did
she do you always play breath wild and
tears of the Kingdom in English yeah I
might as well there's no Dutch version
although that would be
funny I think
maybe there's an option to have Dutch
text but not voice over for sure there's
German there's french maybe
Italian not
sure probably
Spanish uh wait I wasn't paying
attention what am I supposed to do fight
alongside see re you ask you to meet her
at her at a mural in the underground
shelter oh yeah okay I got
it last time I removed uh this the the
the black screen thingy but then it
doesn't run as
good with the dynamic FPS mod it just
runs so much
smoother less hiccups better frame rate
Dutch and German are very similar uh
they are and they aren't there's certain
words that are similar and obviously
they're both Aryan uh languages for sure
but there's also quite a few big big
differences like if a German just
casually speaks German like on a
normal uh
Tempo we won't be able to understand
them maybe if they slow it down a little
bit you can pick out certain words and
kind of know what they're talking about
but but yeah it's a it's a very
different language when it comes to
pronunciation the German doesn't have
the hard G the sound that's already a
big
difference that's usually what what
trips people up when they try to learn
Dutch my my fiance still cannot
pronounce the G she she just uses
uh like there's two uh two ways to
pronounce the G in Dutch depends on
where you live kind of the dialect
changes you can either do the gurgling
sound or you can do
like more
like that we call that the soft G got
the hard G and the soft G both are
correct both are
fine
uh
Mur standing back to back to three
pillars oh yeah okay got got to do the
three pillars
thingy hissing C cat on yeah yeah yeah
that's what it sounds like so for
example the word uh the word cro means
big uh you can either sayro or you can
sayro and both are are
fine I think wait I I should probably
activate the shrine on top of the on top
of here can I just Dive Right
Through oh oh there's a hot spot here
yep let's see if it takes me all the way
to the
top I think the only other language that
I know of that has that same
sound is like uh Arabic or
something like certain middle eastern
languages have it
too it's not entirely the same but it it
comes pretty
close
the German CH yeah that's more like
sh
Scher so those are the
three
uh there's the other one oh no that's a
shrine I might as well Pinn that one as
well so we at least know where we going
where's the other
one should be
three is the other one
obscured can't see
it that's
weird well we'll we'll see when we get
there
oh we can use that to hit you right
up
oh holy sh a is a lot harsher I don't
know I'm I cannot really hear the
difference between a lot of the Slavic
languages they all sound very similar to
me the same way a lot of people will
probably confuse
Dutch and
German or the Chinese uh languages CU
there's a lot of
them that that's the weirdest thing to
me is
that I know China is very big so
obviously there's going to be different
people speaking different dialects but
there's like whole different languages
and they are incompatible with each
other do I have bomb flowers please tell
me I have bomb flowers I don't think I I
do have a time bomb
One Last Time
Bomb
yeah anime says I am from Germany but I
but I always play te the kingdom and Bre
wild in English because I like the voice
acting more I can see
that I would probably still play it in
English as well because I play all the
games in
English it it just it would just be
weird to suddenly have it be in Dutch I
know you can you can play Skyward Sword
in Dutch and like the names are
different
the like there's just whole there's so
many things that are completely
different like uh demise in Dutch is
called fatal
lot fatal and I have no idea why because
that's not even a Dutch word it doesn't
mean
anything why why they change the
name who
knows oh the other one is not
raised H
[Music]
gotcha my Omar is from red and bck
but I've only been to Amsterdam if
you've been to Amsterdam then you
technically haven't really been to the
Netherlands in my opinion because even I
feel like I'm in a in a different
country when I'm in because everybody
just speaks Dutch there or speaks
English there
like it it it's like one of those
International
cities
rise from the
earth there we
go oh that cost stamina I didn't know
that there we
[Music]
go it's making a a Triforce guys it's
the Triforce it is in the
game
yeah it's very Cosmopolitan yeah
exactly is that the what they call it
Cosmopolitan it's just like even I don't
feel at home
there I don't exactly remember if this
was correct but it's making a triangle
uh what did they say I need to
do unite the pillars in light to reveal
the lightning Stone and open the way
open the
way you can hear my voice come to me
I'll await
you reu things the voice and the mural
are connected man' reu is on to
something hey ore how's it going
it's the donster
[Music]
days Triforce isn't in some other games
too like the Minish Cap yeah that's
correct like in in the Minish Cap it's
because it's been sealed Away by raru
not this raru not gloat goat raru but
the the other
raru I'm not sure if I'm just supposed
to go to the middle of the triangle
[Music]
or I'm I totally forgot this part too I
forgot this whole game at this point at
least gameplay
wise hello
C oh you're sick Olive I hope you feel
better
soon
what's this a
melon me
likes forse
goat I'm sure you'll feel uh you'll feel
better soon oh oh oh I can Harvest their
wings oh still got me
you bastard thanks for the help
Tulin I'm just going to blame Tulin
again this whole
episode uh
shocks I actually don't want to
waste uhoh uhoh
man if this was an aine of time Gib
though he would have
already killed
me only when they crawl are they like a
mild
threat someone's been camping here do
you see
that someone left a little uh flaggy
thingy like a Weather Vein
or
n Tulin is okay besides this is not
really Tulin it's it's just ghost it's
ghost Tulin we can we can blame him for
anything he's not real he's just a
hologram what is the best country you
have visited I love uh Estonia isn't it
cold uh the best country when it comes
to to
uh it's a kind of a boring answer but so
far one of my favorite trips like most
beautiful trips was uh Germany the Black
Forest oh no I don't have any
more
bommies I don't have any bombs can I
just throw a rock on it will that do
it no
Twilight Princess uh gibdos are the
scariest says all
it oh yeah they're pretty scary and they
have
swords like what what is like anything
that you give a sword is automatically
more threatening and
scary oh I
see the handle broke can I just use
something else just a weapon or
something I want to cheese
this I know that's not what they want me
to do
but I mean if you're going to give me
the option to do weird
stuff no can I
not there's nothing
I did hear
something something happened oh this one
is not making contact I
see can I spin
it
yeah now we got
it that reminds me of Wind
[Music]
Waker
attach an
apple it's the lightning
Stone a golden
Dorito hey we got 69 viewers
nice nice
nice what if I spin it again now will
will the lightning Stone go
away or did it go away now wait let me
realign
it okay there we go you know what I'm
just going to leave this stick here I'll
sacrifice this
stick for the sake of the the world
so I guess it's in the middle of the
triangle
right I would
say based on the mural you saw the
shelter something should have been
revealed perhaps at the
center weoo
time lyc Brad says greetings monster
love your channel thank
you I'm sorry for not having uploaded
for a while it's been I've been taking a
break today is my last day off from not
creating
content I promised myself I would take
the whole of January off just to
recharge my
battery get those creative juices
flowing
again oh it's fake
Zelda and it's Patricia
do you see that link it's
Zelda no it's
not
oh do you not count streaming as
creating content not really I'm just
hanging out with you guys playing the
game that's not really doesn't feel like
work maybe if you do it
daily oh that's T and I thought like
someone's coming it's Tulin uh Tulin
ghost
oh so what's next for you
uh going to try to tackle a few more
General topics I guess things that are
not
really only tied to
Zelda like a last stream I was already
talking about that I want to do a video
about environmental storytelling in
general which will have Zelda mixed in
because in my opinion bre the wild had
one of the best environmental
storytelling in any
game but it's going to be more of a
general
topic hungry Apple says if you ever if
you ever feel like streaming again maybe
you can consider playing your favorite
Zelda uh well I don't really have a
favorite but like it it changes I have a
top five and two of two of which I've
already played on
stream I wish it was the arbitus ground
[Music]
Ador you're kind of working on content
right now for the next video that's true
that's true
yeah I am recording for it show that's
part of making the video but that video
is it's going to be a while before that
goes
up there will be other videos in between
for
sure or else I'm not going to have any
uploads in February
either
wait how does her this is just her thing
right the
bubble come on reu is she just going to
stand there oh nope she's taking
off I am probably going to die on the
boss in this game because in this
Dungeon Because I do not have a whole
lot of
Hearts oh why am I collecting melons I
wanted to eat
them
um but yeah even in my first playthrough
which I think I had considerably more
Hearts than right
now but I died at least four times
because this was the first dungeon I did
on my first
playthrough so I I I don't know I had
like seven or eight
hearts uh CH chardan says playing tears
of the Kingdom now is the order
generally SE to be reto Zora Goron then
gudo uh yeah I think
so I do feel like the Garuda one is the
most difficult one it it has the hardest
boss for
sure but when you talk to Pura I I do
think she points out she kind of points
you in the direction of Theo first and
then after that the gorons then the Zora
so it's almost the same as in bre the
wild
oh it didn't reach all the
way I just always go to the to the
desert first so both in breath the Wild
and in this game I did the grudo section
first oh
no it's a giant
moth it's stiring up the
sand it must be responsible for all
this no that would be Gondor let take it
down
together
has to be
le uhoh
uhoh those probably hurt where did it
go yes that's
good
that's
it her design looks amazing and her
fight is pretty hard
yeah it is it is the hardest B like this
one was the only one that really gave me
trouble granted I did not have a lot of
hearts
and I don't think I prepared a lot of
meals
either can I just kill these two
hives just out of precaution you know
yep there we
go
[Music]
uh I think you can use fire too right
it's not just lightning
yeah
wait am I oh my bow broke
again I shouldn't waste these I should
probably save them for the dungeon
itself
but
only three bows left yeah I I'll
probably get some more inside the
dungeon
maybe how many arrows do I have left uh
I I'll probably find
some if not then so be it we can always
exit and get new
ones let's make this even harder for
ourselves than it already
is what are your thoughts on the spirit
Temple well it's not really a in my
opinion like the the construct Factory
technically
is I like the music inside the spirit
Temple but I I yeah I was a little
disappointed that it wasn't an actual
like bigger dungeon like this when I saw
the building itself from the outside I
thought oh cool but it's just one boss
battle which is a little bit of a shame
but it is what it
is uh
no
yeah I feel like the lightning Temple
kind
of it comes the the closest to a Zelda
dungeon but still not
really uh
uh I'll just I'll bring a torch then
let's make this more
cinematic let's Indiana Jones
this what are your thoughts on the Paper
Mario games for switch uh I haven't
played them on switch but Thousand-Year
Door is one of my favorite games of all
time like it ranks up up there for
sure it's it's in my top 10 favorite
games of all time it it outclasses some
of the Zelda games for
me it's such an amazing game and I like
the first one too but thousand your
doors even bigger is there something
down here probably just a trap
right yeah I'm not even going to
try I should really make a weapon that
can kill these
guys not just use my bow every
time
uh just give those yeah the and uh you
mean inside the dungeon
itself is that a gyto that in inside oh
no that's a
sword I cannot pick it up can I get rid
of
anything I don't know why this one is
not rendering
properly I don't really want to waste
any of these
weapons uh I I'll get it later I don't
even think I have anything to to fuse it
to that would outclass anything unless I
picked up some more stuff in the
meantime not
really yeah I
know it's only
18 and this is a onetime use
thingy I guess I could fuse a ruby to
it yeah let's do
that uh which one should I get rid
of I think they're just going to keep
giving you I I'll get rid of the torch I
mean what's the
point uh
yeah
no come
on uh there we
go I still know how to play the
game
uhoh I wonder what's down there
yeah the music is really
good there's a new Indiana Jones game
coming out
really do you play as a grandpa or as
young
Indie attach a li I don't have any Liz F
horn I I haven't bought any of
them I kind of wonder what's down there
but
we yeah they keep giving you those
cororo
leaves I know you got to just block that
oh you know what I'm just going to take
a quick peat down
here
ow
uh can I just recall this yeah I could
but you can also Ascend through
this dungeon is surprisingly dark
like most places in in Zelda in this one
are not that dark aside from the depths
the caves are surprisingly well lit for
a cave even when there's no no light
sources around it at
all I'll just recall
it
hello these Flames make it impossible to
go
further these Flames make it impossible
to go further what what shall we
do I guess the fire temple is kind of
indoors yeah it
is sort
of did I fit this
through
yeah
there are light flowers in caves yeah
but not everywhere hey the Flames have
gone out there's definitely some ambient
lighting that they put in
there like have you ever been in a in a
real natural cave it's it's Pitch
Black it's one of the scariest things
ever we went into a natural cave in
kurasa on one of the
islands and uh at some point they turn
off all the lights and it's
just 100% Darkness it's like even darker
than when you close your your
eyes uhoh
Noe
nailed
it uh should I can I should I cook
something I do have
yeah whatever shall we
cook I don't have any hearty stuff just
throw some random random stuff
together I know it will cancel oh I do
have a hearty
truffle but that's a bit Overkill though
I only have five hearts or six six
hearts so whatever I cook it's going to
it's going to be Overkill
but let's just pretend that did not
happen yeah exactly well it didn't knock
me out like knock me out or knock me
over it skimmed
me
what was your first retro console uh the
NES see even without Hardy stuff I'm
already getting five hearts for every
meal so I think I'm just going to hang
on to that Hardy truffle for a bit
longer
I don't want to waste it maybe I'll I'll
eat it if the battle goes really really
bad and I and I end up going through all
these
meals uh ran
out I'll just put some fire fruit in
there or should I save the fire fruit
yeah I should probably save the fire
food I'll just use the
melons
did you play Paper Mario origami King
yeah and I I liked it I didn't like the
combat obviously a whole lot because
there's no reward well let's just put it
that way I the the combat itself was
okay there's just no incentive to do it
it just wastes
resources the fireball stopped I'm on my
but I really like the story it was a
step in the right direction
and the art style is just absolutely
beautiful origami King is one of my
favorite switch games in in terms of uh
in terms of art style it just looks
amazing so
colorful I I love the
humor uh
uh lightning
ready doesn't work I have to activate it
first see we found a bow we're
good oh now it
activates I think it's not active yet or
is it oh yeah it
is and my sword broke
no leave me alone get him
tulan oh my my arrow caught fire from
the torch here the the the whatever it's
called uh I will just waste one of my
weaker weapons on
this save my best weapons for the boss
we're going to need
it I hope we can make it before the
state of play
starts if not we'll just continue this
uh in the weekend oh there's a secret
room secret secret
oh I got
you uh yeah I guess this one will break
the fastest
what is above here if I if I just Ascend
up here what will happen will I just
appear on the roof probably let's try it
you can cancel out of it
anyway I'm just curious to see where we
end
up
yep
Hello
Goodbye Tulin can fight gibdos yeah why
can I not equip him with uh different
arrows give him fire
arrows
what's your favorite 2D Zelda oh that's
a difficult
one probably A Link to the Past still or
maybe Minish
Cap oh no he's got a bow and I only have
two
hearts should I Chow Down on some GTO
guts probably not a good
idea I'll save the fish for
cooking I just go for
it or should I just I'll just waste all
my Splash fruits we don't use them
anyway I do actually want to keep some
of the ice fruits uh let's
see I think we're
good probably not we'll probably still
get one shot at oh seared steak to the
rescue I forgot I bought that at the
bizar
are ice ice fruits are usually
good uh I should have gotten more
stuff I just I don't want to waste any
meals no not that
one
[Music]
no G you you you crap my style ow and
I'm dead Jesus Christ I should have
eaten one more
thing just nothing can kill you in one
hit I think if you have Full
Hearts oh see you see you around geod
Dragon thanks for dropping
by Kieran Buckley says I love the Oracle
games oh yeah the Oracle games are so
underrated in my opinion I just start
right here again
uh I still have my seared
steak I cannot eat this no
there we
go now you cannot hurt
me Jesus all
right I didn't know he could do
that
this guy is Pretty
Tough oh my
God everything is going
wrong you know what I'll just use a
stronger weapon that that usually
helps Ura says my favorite 2D Zelda is
links Awakening uh yeah that one is
pretty damn cool as
well I personally like the Oracle games
more
but like it's very close
I think they refined a couple of things
in the Oracle games CU since it's almost
the
same uh I still have my my cor Leaf
thingy oh
no that wasn't supposed to
happen come
on
I'm too
aggressive we'll just cook up a bunch of
new stuff before we get to the boss I
don't even think we're going to make it
to the boss to be honest we haven't even
gotten to the central room uh Central
room yet I think the state of play is in
half an hour or
something yeah I did not come prepared
at
all
I'm also almost out of cooking
thingies uh where's my fish
at are you going to live stream state of
play uh probably
not cuz there's not like 90% of state of
play is not going to be for me I'm just
going to be checking it out on the side
to see if they announce anything Silent
Hill related cuz we still don't know
anything about the remake of two or any
of the newer stuff they've
announced
oh
no I was sure that's that was going to
work
yeah yeah I think ratas also knows more
about all the other titles that they are
going to show like a lot of it I'm not
even going to know what oh yeah of
course mirror Shield
thingy
uh it's not it's not a lightning
switch
I don't think there's going to be any
other big announcements Elden ring DLC
for sure is not going to be on a state
of play I
think February 2nd is Sonic's Groundhog
Day how's
that the new Silent Hill written by
junjiito sounds terrifying I hope it's a
good game is that the Japanese themed
one that we saw or is that the towns
fall Town fall whatever it it was this
is a really dumb name Silent Hill Town
fall it's like a a
pun Senor Divine Beast says hello nice
to see you are in the best Temple in the
game yeah
for
sure okay it is's the Japanese one okay
I got it yeah it looks interesting it
just doesn't look like a silent hill
game to me I I I feel like it could have
just as well been titled something
completely different but of course it's
banking on the Silent Hill name which is
kind of a shame that people will only be
interested if it carries a a title of
something we already know something
that's already been established the four
batteries and it will function once
more but
yeah it it did look uh it did look
pretty good although there's not much to
say just yet
but the fact that it's coming from Japan
is already giving me much better uh
because normally I'm not like that at
all like oh everything that comes from
Japan is
better like I'm not a wee uh that way
but when it comes to horror
especially horror games the for some
reason the Japanese are just so much
better at it than than the even in
movies that's the
case I don't know what it is like
westerners are just so terrible at doing
new stuff or doing something really new
like unfamiliar disturbing when it comes
to
horror it's always you can even see it
in our monster designs you know whenever
we design monsters we just take
something that's already kind of like
you know a little bit of Godzilla here a
little bit of giant alligator there and
the Japanese are just like what if we
create a deer but instead of antlers
they are two legs and he also
has a goat's head as a tail something
like that you know they're they just do
the weirdest stuff when it comes to
their monster
designs taker says
I think the next direct might be a
snoozefest but there might be one heavy
hitter anything Zelda would be crazy uh
thank you as always for the donation
taker always appreciate it and uh yeah
it kind of depends how far they are
right now when it comes
to um you know like the switch 2 or
switch successor whatever it's going to
be called
if they're not ready to show anything in
like when it comes to that uh oh I think
I should eat something
again but uh
yeah if there's going to be a heavy
hitter it might just it might not be
Zelda since the tears of the Kingdom
just came out but I hope so maybe
they'll announce some ports or a soft
remake of
something which would be nice anything
Zelda is always is welcome in my
book I don't have anything to can I just
eat an opal come on he's he's eating
Rock roast he can eat
anything still waiting for that tears of
the Kingdom DLC it's not going to happen
bro Nintendo has just been like nope
we're not doing it
sorry uh I don't want to waste any of
these for a quarter of a
heart can I eat a pine
cone that's that's digestible
right and I'm screwed I did not prepare
I'm also not going to waste a hearty
truffle Nintendo has closed directs with
has closed directs with remasters and
not brand new
games
yeah they they also said no Skyward
Sword HD I think did they did they ever
I think it was people who said that
would never happen
right cuz I remember some sort of there
was some sort of conference or or
whatever and and anuma asked the
audience if they wanted to see Skyward
Sword on
switch
yeah screw him up I'm just I'm not going
to say the f word because uh they will
for sure again like restrict my
monetization
uhoh wait can I do the
style luckily he
missed that was really close
actually
I'm out of
stamina there we
go another bow oh I'm I'm out of Bow's
space bow
space what kind of bow is this
Mighty yeah then I'm going to get rid of
one of
these B
show make a mirror Shield okay
I think he dropped one here right
yeah no oh he already has a mirror
attached to
it uh we'll we'll probably find another
mirror
soon I don't think we can do anything
here right or can we open this
[Music]
no I think we have to descend into this
cage if I remember correctly or drop in
from
above but yeah nothing to see
here
nope do you miss the old Champions uh I
do think the old Champions were more
more interesting than the than the new
ones even though they're not technically
Champions they're
sages but you know it's it's pretty
similar at this
point
huh up we
go hungry Apple says anyway I'm headed
out thank you for dropping by as always
and uh have a good
one uh is it starting the state of
play it's like still like
uh like 18 minutes or something
right yeah 18 minutes to go
okay then I can still screw around a
little bit I'll try to stream a little
bit longer on uh either Saturday or
Sunday depending on my schedule
we can go
higher I think I can just
uh yeah I'll just go all the way up I'm
going to leave reu
behind Euro says question do you think
that the story of Tears of the Kingdom
can work in age of calami timeline
why uh
I'll I don't
know I mean both stories are not that
amazing to me so I don't really
care and these guys are storm troopers
when it comes to their
aim oh another gudo bow
uh let me see but uh do you mean like
the part where the Champions or
Champions the the new Champion like
sidon and stuff they should remember
that they went to another timeline are
you referring to that
part
I mean I don't think the story is really
Canon the but that you know I'm not the
one who has to decide that of course I'm
not a Authority on that but personally I
think uh it should be considered a Side
Story age of
calamity
okay oh I still have a strong zonite
sword do I have anything good to fuse at
too yeah I
do I always confuse Ultra hand and fuse
when it comes to the effect it looks so
similar
oh oh we can make a mirror shield now
because we have two of
them
uh
yeah it looks so funny just just giant
thing sticking off out of his
back oh Euro says no I mean after they
defeat the calamity
they find ganondorf's corpse oh that's
why well technically they should right
in that timeline if if let's say for for
a moment that it is a cannon story then
yeah in that timeline they should also
find his corpse for
sure absolutely I never thought of that
that's actually uh that's actually
pretty
smart so even in that timeline they're
going to have to deal with all this
uh snooze poo says that's a great name
by the way I think zi lights work too oh
yeah I don't think I have any right
no I've rushed through everything I i'
have done no shrines except the first
few where you get the
powers where you get the
power I think this one is already
position good
uh I got to get rid of that one over
there the only thing I might consider
upgrading a little bit as my stamina
because it's just really
annoying
uh let's see oh that one is already good
too so then we go to that
one
there we
go did you get the master sword yet uh
no I did
not we do have to do that part too
because I want to record that part of
the footage too that's not something I
can skip you can skip it because you'll
get the master sword during the final
fight either way it's kind of funny how
that
works Zelda just shows up and you'll get
the sword
regardless which is not how it worked in
in the breath the wild there you did
just didn't get it at
all um okay this is going to be a very
stupid question I was reading chat when
I activate activated this
thingy what happened what did something
activate what what
changed is there something that changed
I was not paying attention at
all so if you guys can just do me a
solid and uh make me look less like an
idiot uh Luke says to be fair I got the
master sword right before going into the
lightning Temple
okay I think some statue
moved which
one
I should pay more attention when I'm
playing oh my God wait I can just remove
it right won't it do it again I can see
what it
does we'll just activate
again
no thank you nas for not thinking I'm an
idiot I I I just I genuinely was not
paying
attention I cannot read chat and play at
the same time I don't know how some
streamers do it but I I just I I
can't I've tried many times I I just
don't have that type of brain that can
do all all that stuff at the same
time yeah something must have open was
it this
one
I don't think I have to go in here just
yet I'll follow the light so I can just
go up
there isn't that just a switch though up
there we we'll go and
see how would Aster react
gondorf not
sure he he seemed pretty okay with
everything Ganon was doing or Calamity
Calamity Ganon was
doing like all the crazy stuff
sacrificing the yiga souls and all
that you are a genius Luke
right thank
you oh this is where we dropped down
into the
thingy
almost
overcorrected now we just get go get oh
there she
is oh Lord she
coming to be fair it's common knowledge
I I just wasn't paying attention to
whatever moved at that moment I was I
thought it like opened up something else
somewhere else you know some other
Statue moved not like at the point I
just saw the light switch and then I
focused my attention to uh why am I
making ex excuses for myself I'm just an
idiot
sometimes I think we will be leaving it
at this soon we'll just go back to the
central chamber and then we'll continue
you next
time cuz I think state of play is going
to start in about eight
minutes so if you guys have any more
like last questions feel free to ask
them
now I think this is where the thing oh
no no that that's not
here
we'll we'll continue this next time it's
actually a pretty long dungeon now that
I think about it it's definitely the
longest of all of them I think kind of
depends on how much you know about it
too
but I know
nothing after my first play through I
kind of just left it at
this so it's actually fun to play it
play through it
again more link you are made president
of Nintendo what while Jr toy that's a
very big responsibility all of a sudden
what are your first three business
decisions
uh stop attacking people who mod things
let the community be a community and
just let people do things as long as
they they're not making big money off of
it should be
fine uh that's definitely one get more
involved into
Esports because it's the future Esports
is just it draws huge crowds it it
draws huge sales just think about how
many copy more like how many more copies
of Smash Brothers have been
sold because of people watching
tournaments not even playing in
tournaments just watching
them third party support is already
pretty good on the switch compared to
previous titles so they're they're
already on the right track
there I don't know what my last big
business decision would be aside from
just more powerful Hardware stop trying
to find that niche of uh we'll make
weaker Hardware but it's going to be fun
to play still so it doesn't
matter you can still make it pretty
powerful and still have it at a
reasonably low cost I
think I'm kind of tired of uh Nintendo
pretending like they're not part of the
gaming sphere as a whole they're like oh
we we do our own thing we're not really
in the same business yes you are you are
making games Sony and Xbox are making
games you're in the same business
you're just saying that because you
don't want
to you know be compared to the to them
and that's fine you can distance
yourself from
their uh
Direction like they're they're more
focused on Hardcore gaming and they're
more focused on graphics and if you
don't want to do that which that's
totally valid but stop pretending like
you're be more present at other events
like why are why haven't they done
anything at any of the game Awards
anymore the game awards would would be
so much more hype if Nintendo actually
put some effort into it and just
appeared do you consider video games a
sport I would say so yeah if chess can
be considered a
sport like it's a it's a sport where you
think instead of use
your like
uh use your muscles
anything that requires strategy or being
good at
it cuz gaming still is it's also muscle
memory so I guess you are still using
muscles it's just not like physically
intense it's more mentally intense but a
mental sport should be considered a
sport too uh at least in my
opinion
so yes I guess is the short
answer Euro
says uh I mean the Champions could
become sages it's kind of weird to me
how sages and champions are now kind of
the same thing I never consider them to
be the same thing at
all I always figured you know the the
sages are
more like that they're more wise and
more focused on Magic and champions are
just very powerful warriors you
know
time travel does not always change the
timeline agreed if everything and
everyone like step like at the end uh
everyone returns to their own timeline
and nothing substantial has been changed
then
yeah I think uh the timeline should not
be
affected or if it's like a closed time
Loop like in Major's
mask where it's just you're trying
things over and over again until they
succeed is it just going to play that
cut scene every
time oh no that was the other Statue
okay
gotcha
we sage has an incredibly has an
incredibly lose meaning
meaning Zelda to be fair uh has a very
loose meaning I got you okay yeah it
does but like in the in the past sages
are like the way I see it sages are like
these Spiritual Beings whose Essence
keeps getting passed on like I think the
Wind Waker showed it the best uh where
that's why a sage needs to awaken first
because they're basically a bit like the
Avatar they keep
uh inheriting all the memories from
their past lives when whenever they
awaken that's why medley suddenly
understands everything she's just like I
I get it
now and I kind of like that concept that
they are these Spiritual Beings who keep
possessing new
bodies and champions in my opinion were
just very talented Warriors who have
special
powers who are more magically gifted
than other people but that doesn't
necessarily make make them a sage you
know granted this is all based on one
game setting the the the president for
what a sage is and that's Wind Waker I
think I just like the concept they
introduced in Wind
Waker
in fact that that very concept makes
raru in this game kind of make a little
bit more more sense because raru is kind
of also like a shape shifter type of
deal like he
keeps possessing new bodies cuz he can
also change into an owl and all that
stuff uh wait let me see this is
not this is a mirror right
yeah I'm supposed to mirror
it oh get away from
me come on hit
me oh my God okay I think that's the end
of the stream I don't know what happened
there did I electrocute
myself he has a
soul
I don't know what happened there
suddenly there was lightning everywhere
and I
died again because I had a quarter of a
heart less than
full oh I'm I'm just here
again
oh I'm just going to save it
here this is going all the wrong ways
six deaths that's not too bad that's not
too bad there's probably going to get a
a few more from this boss only like this
boss alone is going to take at least I'm
going to predict three
deaths I think I'm going to die three
times on uh on the final
boss not the final final boss but the
the dungeon boss I forgot her forgot her
name Queen Gib
though Ganondorf I'm I'm not sure that
one I don't even know if I'm going to do
Ganondorf on
stream because I I do already have that
uh that that whole SE uh segment
recorded so I don't really need
to but maybe for the fun of it we can do
it I can try with five hearts or six
hearts whatever I have which is going to
be seven after this
dungeon so I I mean I can
try
did you play Chrono Trigger uh not very
far
no I I do still want to I still have it
I I I really want to play it
but it seems like a very long game like
a pretty big time
investment and I already have so little
time to play games in general lately but
especially now that I'm getting back
into creating content again like Zelda
content but
maybe uh someday I I'll get back to it I
think I only played for like three
hours oh yeah uh BH Godly
government what damn what a
name uh but yeah you're welcome thanks
for dropping
by oh you're you're at work yeah that
that helps I I also watch other
streamers when I'm doing work or listen
to
them what's your favorite M master
master sword
scene link getting the master sword I
mean
uh I think this one probably it's it's
the most original Zelda Master Sword
pool I
guess in all the other ones it's always
just pulling it out of the PED
pedestal which is fine but I'm I'm glad
they did something new with it instead
you pull it out of Zelda's
head oh thank you
Javier yeah let's have a a fresh start
this
year uh but yeah anyway thank you all so
much for dropping by on this random
Wednesday night and I will see you in
the weekend I will let you guys know
beforehand uh if it's going to be either
Saturday or Sunday it kind of depends on
my
schedule but uh yeah I'll I'll let you
guys know like on S Saturday afternoon
or something I
will I'll make a community
post all right see you all next time
thank you for dropping by once again and
see you